ciao Maryners!
ecco a voi un nuovissimo VIDEO!
oggi si parla
...ancora
di Natale
MA soprattutto...
di  parenti...
I PARENTI
A NATALE
una cosa che
accomuna tutti noi
ecco, sono sicura
che guardando questo video
ciascuno di voi
mmh..
riconoscerà almeno quei 2
3...4...
5...ma che dico 5!
DIECI PARENTI
ricordatevi di lasciare un
commento qui sotto
facendomi sapere
quali di questi parenti
avete in famiglia
e...
ci vediamo alla fine del video
LA ZIA UBRIACA
che poi,dicamoci la verità
l'unica cosa bella del Natale
è bere e mangiare, MANGIARE E BERE
BERE E MANGIARE
e *versi *
e basta con sto vino portateme la vodka
IL NONNO GENEROSO
Allora per quest' anno
visto che tua mamma mi ha detto che sei stata brava a scuola, che ti sei impegnata
voglio farti un regalo
particolare
Però non dire niente a nonna
eh! mi raccomando
allora..
quest' anno
nonno tuo ti vuole dare
5 EURO!
Grazie......
..........mille
....grazie....
LA MAMMA BIPOLARE
MI SONO STUFATA BASTA!
è TUTTO IL GIORNO CHE PULISCO
CHE LAVO
CUCINO *suoneria*
IO NON SONO LA VOSTRA SCHIAVA *squillo del telefono*
VA BENE!?!?
Carissimaa!
ciao!
ma come stai?
tutto bene grazie
aah mi hanno aiutato TUTTO il giorno
a cucinare, sparecchiare
mi stanno lavando i piatti
sono qua che mi rilasso eheh
LA ZIA INVADENTE
Vorrei fare un brindisi alla Chiara
perchè (non so se lo sapete ancora)
MA è DIVENTATA SIGNORIINAAAA
E....poi facciamo un brindisi anche alla Claudia
perchè si spera che si trovi un uomo.....
prima che......insomma.....signorina....
non lo sia più..........
LA BAMBINA CAPRICCIOSA
MAMMA! ma questo è il mio regalo?
sì tesoro!
lo posso aprire?
NO! I regali si aprono dopo.....AAA
NOOAAHH ADESSOOOOOH
Va bene! aprilo adesso...
*apre il regalo*
AAAAHHHH
*piange*
amore cosa c'è??!!!?
è il regalo che volevi tu??
o non ti piace?
NON MI PIACE UEEE NE VOLEVO DI UN ALTROOOOAA COLOREEEHHHH
*Crack*
AAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAA
ELENCATRICE DI MALANNI
Va che anno sfortunato AAA
la cataratta ,che me l'hanno
tolta
poi la febbra
l'influenza testinale
ma niente in confronto ala mia amica della parrocchia!!!!!!
le hanno trovato prima le emorroidi,
poi le è venuta la salamellosi perchè
mangiava la salamella
poi il teurismo
che faceva aria
AAAAAAAAAA
LO ZIO SIMPATICONE
INCREDIBBILE VERO?
ADESSO VE NE RACCONTO UN'ALTRA!
IL COLMO PER Babbo Natale?
AVERE UN FIGLIO CHE SI CHIAMA PASQUALEEE
HAHAHHA AH UN' ALTRA ,UN'ALTRA!
IL COLMO PER UN DENTISTA????'
MANGIARE LA PASTA AL DENTE!!! HAHAHAHAH
L'ULTIMA! L'ULTIMA!
il colmo per un pavimento
AVERE UNA BRUTTA CERA HAHAHAH
LA NONNA CHE FA LE PREDICHE
MA cosa fai sempre
Attaccata a sto telefonino?
ciò.......guarda che alla tua età avevo già 3 lavori..
aspettavo tuo zio....
portavo a pascolare le vacche eh...
facevamo il latte buono!
no le porcherie che vi mangiate voi oggi
la cellulite a me non mi veniva mica
eh.....eh
ma poi guardami un po' ,guardami un po'....
sei bianca!!! Nadia
guarda che sta qua
e' anemica!!!
ZIA MASTERCHEF
Buono eh......brava!
il Gateau era buono....mancava un po' di sale eh
poi,la ricetta originale,quella che faccio io
ha anche la pancetta...il cumino eh e ci metto
il taleggio che si fonde dentro.....eh però
guard...brava!
buono!
ZIA PERMALOSA
COSA VORRESTI DIRE? che non sono
brava quanto te?
vuoi un premio per essere la cuoca più brava della famiglia!!????!
brava, brava!
vuoi gli applausi?
buon Natale anche a te-sei una
stron*beep*-
vuoi farmi fare brutta figura davanti alla mamma!
io almeno mi sono impegnata!....
*piange* BASTA!
ME NE VADO!
LA ZIA SPAMMATRICE
SENTITE QUESTA! "ciao,
mi serve un piccolo favore,
non è un gioco!
Dio ti ha visto soffrire per qualcosa e dice che sta arrivando una benedizione!!!
se credi in Dio manda questo messaggio a 20 persone!
PER FAVORE NON IGNORARE!"
VE LO MANDO SUBITO!!!
NON IGNORATELO EH!
LA ZITELLA
eh...eh...intanto io
sono arrivata a 83 anni zitella MA felice, senza problemi
senza delusioni
perchè gli uomini eh,
pensano a una cosa sola SONO TUTTI MAIALI
MEGLIO SOLI CHE CORNUTI!
LA ZIA LOGORROICA
MARYNA! c'è la zia Rosanna al telefono!
DAI che ti vuole fare gli auguri!!
...ciao zia.....
CIAO TESORO COME STAI??
AH CHE BELLO SENTIRTI!
SAI COSA AVEVO PENSATO ?
CHE PER QUESTO NATALE TI DO QUEI CIOCCOLATINI CHE TI PIACCIONO TANTO                            ...si....si
LI VOLEVO COMPRARE PERò,SAI
SONO STATA BLOCCATA
LA DIVA INCOMPRESA
Ma non vè l'ho mai raccontato
che io ero una prima ballerina del
Bagaglino
io e la Pamela Paratti
sorelle! ehehe
poi ho sposato lo zio Luigi e la mia vita è andata in frantumi
ahh..
sennò a quest'ora...ERO MEGLIO DELLA BELEN
LA RELIGIOSA
Buon appetito!
aspettate!
oggi è nato il santissimo Signore
rendiamogli grazia
con una preghiera
preghiamo insieme
LA CUGINA INVIDIOSA
Ehy!
embè???
allora che t'hanno regalato?
alora mi hanno regalato l'Iphone nuovo e papà mi ha dato 1000 euro
infatti sono contentissima
a me papà me ne ha dati 10000, calcola
che già 2000 li ho spesi
poi, vabbè, mi hanno fatto la Porche!
la macchina? ma tu non hai la patente...
ma..ho comprato pure quella!!
ah...
vabè...
LA ZIA CATTIVA
E quindi adesso hai 16 anni,giusto?
sei un po' ingrassata, lo sai vero?
guarda la zia te lo dice perchè ti vuole TANTO bene
i kili che prendi a qust'età
non te li togli mai più...
IL CUGINO SBORONE
Uè raga, allora ,come la va'?
tutto bene?????
cos'è 'sta poverata!? TIRATE FUORI LO SHAMPOO
CHE SI SCIABOLA!
AH NON SCIABOLATE???
BARBONI!
LA ZIA SOCIAL
Ma aspetta che vi racconto 'na cosa!
l'altro giorno sono andata al castello di Rivoli con Giorgio, mi ha fatto
una foto col castello dietro
bellissima!
l'ho SUBITO messa su instàgràmme
e ho preso 12 like!
non era mai successo!
a proposito,ora mi faccio un selfie
con l'albero
*scatto*
IL NONNO DORMIGLIONE
Ebbene abbiamo mangiato!
eh! abbiamo
bevuto!
e mo'
dormiamo!
nu' poco EH
ma che è successo??
dove sono!?
CARMELA!
DOVE SEI???
TUTTI VE NE SIETE ANDATI!?
ah..
eccoci purtroppo arrivati alla fine
del video,spero tantissimo che vi sia piaciuto
e fatemi sapere quali di questi parenti/personaggi vi è piaciuto di più!
e mi raccomando,se non lo avete ancora fatto ricordatevi
di iscrivervi al canale
e,se volete essere aggiornati su TUTTITUTTITUTTITUTTI
I video,attivate le notifiche
cliccando la campanella vicino al tasto "iscriviti"
METTETEMI TANTI LIKE E SEGUITEMI SU TUTTI I SOCIAAL
Instagram,facebook e musical.ly
ADOROH! CIAO!
SOTTOTITOLI DI CACCA ROSA